hi Ariana how I I'm really good thank
you but this is so exciting tell me how
you feel about being the face of Viva
Glam of spokesperson I feel so excited
and honored and nervous and thrilled but
yeah I've loved Mac since I was a little
girl and it's always been my favorite
makeup brand but the most important
thing about all of this is that with the
lipstick and the lip gloss every penny
made off the two goes towards people
affected by HIV and AIDS thanks to the
MAC AIDS Fund so that's why I'm here and
growing up how where were you of HIV in
the eight because I think also for your
generation and obviously when I grow up
you know that was very prevalent I say
yeah you're fans you know younger
generation it's important that someone
like you who is a role model kind of
talks about I mentioned because maybe
they might not be as aware of it because
I am because a lot of people do think
that in this day and age that's not as
prominent or it's not around and you
know there's medication that helps
people live longer and you know it camp
you know
prevents it from being transmitted but
you know it is still a humongous problem
worldwide I think living today they're
around like 37 million people affected
by HIV and AIDS yeah and not many people
know that so thank you for shining a
light it's important and of course we
got to talk about the other six yes so
you're wearing the dark one I'm wearing
the light you are I hope great I was
gonna wear the dark on my cellular okay
I've got a way so that's good let's talk
through them okay so you're wearing this
this is the one that you're wearing it's
sort of the idea I guess the story
behind it is supposed to be a good girl
by day bad girl by night because yeah
you're the guy I'm the bad girl today
but I feel like you know people are
always trying to label me or pin me down
as either a good girl or a bad girl and
I'm like we all have a naughty side we
all have a sweet side and I think that
we should be able to play up with both
of them and I'm I do cuz for me it's
interesting that you are doing a dark
lipstick because you're really known I
mean for a new or a new a gap the cap I
yes so I do want to ask you because I
think it's one of the hardest things to
do yeah Kat I did that become you I do
my horribly every day yeah yeah I do
mind horribly every day of my life
Harpal don't it's not it looks amazing
but what I keep doing how it's horrible
chess meets Harlem um I don't know you
know I learned from my mom who literally
does her whole face of makeup in the car
like she'll be like uh-huh
I don't like okay mom how are you like
and her like it makes it onto your face
what was it's great but yeah so I don't
know it's prayer in practice for a good
cat I some days my cat eye looks amazing
and I'm like I killed it no but it was
honestly it always looks so good and I
do think one of the hardest things to do
but I can't believe you actually did you
do your makeup yourself most of the time
I just do that I just like to do my
liner oh yeah cuz it's fun and it feels
good
hey thank you so much thank you so much
you